okay
hollywood pessy
i'm high i'm really high too pessy
showed up after showing up at the met
gala and decided oh i'm gonna just i
guess i guess i'm bored anyway i'll just
have some fun everyone thought that was
kim kardashian somebody had that that
was me
making fox looks look i don't care what
anybody says megan fox is smoking hot
god damn
but her face looks weird i actually have
i don't care i have a shut up i have a
picture of pessy at the met gala here it
is
there he is damn pesky how did you
there's pets
why are you wearing bed sheets cheer me
out okay
let's zoom out it took
a lot of butter to get me into that you
literally got to be honest with you
buddy though you look great yeah
why are there two men kissing on your
shirt
i don't know if you can a team of
midgets okay so okay so those aren't two
men kissing that's a man absorbing a
woman into his face and uh and those
sleeves for some reason were filled with
bees so i had to move very carefully
oh god do you think you look like a
human jellyfish fashion's weird
you look ridiculous
um and then of course guys don't forget
on your way on your way to work today to
peg the patriarchy that's right
make sure that you're pegging the
patriarchy
hey peg
yes yeah make sure you peg the
patriarchy on your way to work
and uh another one that i really really
enjoyed was aoc's tax the rich
tax the rich dress that you wanted to
wear but aren't they in a place 30 000
it cost to attend
per person
per person so it should have said tax me
yeah exactly tax
please tax the [ __ ] rich
that screenshot her dress looks like it
just says tario yeah well well that's
dario is the restaurant she used to
bartend at before she became a
congressman she used to work at tario
and then of course there's also hot
women there yes megan fox was there and
yes she is still hot and if you even
pretend that her face is weird i'll
punch you in yours okay
good i didn't say that she's a weird
feet
that's fine she has a word thing and she
has weird thumbs
yeah she's toe thumbs yeah just told and
that's fine and i'll give you that and
then of course um the haircut of a
chinese boy
the one that uh she knows what i'm into
yeah
[Laughter]
that's what frozen asian this is frozen
asian at the met gala and uh i guess kim
kardashian decided to go as a [ __ ]
terrorist i don't know what this is
about
what the [ __ ] yeah dude dude
the [ __ ] the thing is is like all these
people tell you how to vote and how to
live your life and how they're better
than you and then you look at these
people and you're like
wait what we're supposed to take these
people seriously hey you look like
you're you're about to be burned for
losing your honor so maybe you should
shut up
it's official
yeah she looks like she's about to she
should be protecting palpatine like
what is this look
pessy it's official zentai has made it
to the united states oh my god
she's like a she's like a i don't know a
linen covered [ __ ] yeah she looks like a
background extra in the get your freak
on music video
[Laughter]
bum bum
uh
so yeah man we have megan fox obviously
looked hot yes um but of course beg the
patriarchy's up there for me
it really it really is
royce has something because that's like
smokey eyes though no no no no
not that she's hot but what i mean is
the the do you want to be pegged the
adult the adult bib that she's wearing
is very fashionable and then i thought
that was body armor uh
no but again this is honestly this is
still my honestly my favorite was still
this one
i i don't know what it is about this one
dan levy
[ __ ]
is so good it's that's an outfit
can we talk about those those [ __ ] me
eyes he's given right now can we talk
about how all the all the stars got to
be without mask but all the dirty press
people had to have to wear masks there
all the
gross
people he he couldn't find a mask that
didn't clash with whatever the [ __ ] it
is
dude remember when they used to have
these in like people who were tuxes and
women were ball gowns and now they're
[ __ ] this guy looks like a flying
squirrel like
what are we doing
he looks like the he looks like the
cover art for that book disc world yeah
i mean this is really bad this looks
like resonance this looks like ready
player 69
this is just a bigger target matador
yeah i know this looks like if they made
a new live-action street fighter movie
this is what vega would dress like
you know okay like
that's that's that's what i think i
gotta actually get down with that though
no you see the the design wasn't uh
painted onto the fabric uh famed artist
lupin
uh
put a bunch of paint in his [ __ ] and
farted
farted on there
oh god and that's a good point like that
that looks that looks great
i mean it looks terrible but for for
these [ __ ] they think they look
great but then you have to sit like this
for five hours
jokes on you
and it's a gala so they actually have
like a meal right so you're sitting
there and your big sleeves are getting
your tomato bisque it's just
dipping into your food you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
guess i can't return this after uh yeah
you're right maybe he's hiding maybe
he's hiding bread rolls in those sleeves
for the bisque yeah you know what else
is weird jonah hill almost wore the same
outfit they would have looked ridiculous
how embarrassing jonah hill that's why
i'll always love matt and trey right
when they went to the uh to the emmys
and showed a dress like women and were
tripping when that was one of the best
stories
one of them dressed like j-lo one was
dressed like jayla the other one was
just like a girl but they they both were
dressed like girls but then they were
tripping balls
as they were like they said they did way
too much acid and they just showed up
and then instead we have whatever the
[ __ ] this is and any time uh a reporter
asked matt and trey a question they just
respond with lovely night beautiful
night wonderful night you're having a
beautiful night wonderful night
uh
god i love this stuff like you know i
mean first off because
dude they're so easy to make fun of like
they like they they
this is like that level where you're so
out of touch from any sort of reality
where you're like yeah yeah i'm just
gonna wear this and you know i'm just
like you i i'm just like you and then
staying on a soapbox for three hours
yeah just sit there and talk about a
talk about we have to stop the spread
i'm [ __ ] sorry cirque du soleil
performer i'm not gonna listen to you
you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
get down from those trapeze and talk to
me like a man i don't like modern
liberace
no
no please that's not even that's not
even fair at least liberace was talented
he could play an instrument
uh at least liberace had the common
sense to pretend he wasn't gay okay
um
it's confirmed bachelor dan levy
okay confirm bachelor
[Laughter]
oh man i love this stuff i was just
going through all these pictures now
look all these are great yes i know i
know i know all these are amazing and
all these are great but but
look
what would the met gala be
without
some white male representation can i can
we agree with that of course
yeah we're looking at it no no no no
straight white male representation
all right and now
now we're talking oh that's an adorable
little child
frozen how did you get the invite to the
met gala man
well you see
i had to
go through a lot of this this looks this
looks like
when this will say can i borrow can i
borrow your suit to go to court like
that are those l.a gears yes
no you know they're probably like they
basically are late gears but some storm
design they're probably like 40 dollar
shoes
okay why it's make a wish wish was to go
to the met gala remember remember he
start he started on trailer park boys
look at him now look at him now he just
finished his last round of chemo look at
him now he's stressed he is dressed like
julian going to court it's perfect i
love it
but no this is like look i understand
you're going to lop your tits off i mean
whatever man that that's your
prerogative i honestly don't care
you couldn't get like a tailored suit
though yeah seriously like you couldn't
borrow a season sorry suit you're about
the same size
chapter house goes i'm a real boy
the pinocchio looking ass over here
he somehow found the last jc penny
he got the suit off the rock
right off the rack
hey mr batista i forgot my suit do you
do you have a
an extra one yeah yeah can i use your
cummerbund this is this is like when you
show up to a restaurant that requires a
suit jacket and you don't have one so
they give you the loner
here you go
wear this one you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] man
this is amazing like i love the met gala
she's dressed like she's dressed like
the son of a canadian prime minister at
a press conference okay first off he
don't that name oops all right that's
elliot all right
that's that's elliot roger page and you
will absolutely respect him third the
third elliott roger page the third and
you want to squash him
oh he's also a lawyer yes
elliot roger page esquire dmd all right
there it is that's the full name
no no no no remember
chances are
dds oh dds okay fair enough all right
this is fine so we're doing great
everything's good
can i can i say these people are
convincing you there's a pandemic
ravaging the country and they do this
like come on like have some like have
some common sense right some brevity
yeah jesus christ
this is my fav so remember so again this
is my favorite straight white male there
for sure
for sure by the way hold on the correct
name is somebody added this for me it's
elliott
roger page
esquire dmd the rumble okay that's
the rumble
can we can we talk about the fact that
the search for curly's gold
i'm pretty sure that's like a plastic
flower too right oh that's not a real
flower that's not a real man there's a
lot of things that aren't real in this
photo how dare you squirts water when
you look into it squirts water it makes
a whistle noise
no that's her ring that's his ring
you [ __ ] new batman villain
oh [ __ ]
it looks like a [ __ ] pre-pubescent
riddler like what are we gonna do with
this the sleeves are so big that it
hides the hand buzzer on her head on his
hand sorry pre-pubescent riddler it's
all knock knock jokes
oh [ __ ]
no not fat man who's there
orange orange hue
orange you glad i didn't blow up three
schools instead of just this one
just the suit too like the pants are all
proper but like a suit he looks like he
looks like one of them he looks like one
of the parkland survivors at a funeral
jesus christ
oh my [ __ ] god
i'm if you're gonna go go hard
wow
oh elmo achieved mark it down
10 17.
that was it that was a self-ammo by the
way yeah that was this weird
rare self elmo
oh [ __ ]
god damn it and there were i think he
wore this and he thought yeah he looked
in the mirror and he goes yep
nailed it
hey you don't know what he went through
to become a real boy
we found the lead for the new live
live-action james and the giant peach
he threw the keys to his peach to the
valet out front here keep it running
[Laughter]
don't mind the giant front well in this
case elliot so little it's just james
and the normal-sized peach
james said james and the apricot
oh [ __ ]
okay enough guys okay we have to be
serious we have to be serious this is
not funny anymore move on
right in with the fire oh [ __ ] crazy
christ dude
hold on let me put on my serious suit
there we go
[Laughter]
now i'm ready someone in the chat
earlier said that this outfit looks like
a butter a caterpillar was turning into
a butterfly but just gave up
this looks like
this outfit looks like when frank when
frank was naked and got out of the couch
oh i see his head is the clitoris i get
it now you know what this looks like
when you try to when you try to fold the
fitted sheet and give up
ah [ __ ] it i'm not doing it [ __ ] this
[ __ ] i'll just
it's when you take the it's when you
take the fitted sheet out of the dryer
and there's a bunch of stuff bunched up
in it yeah it's still wet
it's got like four pairs of underwear
and some socks
tucked into a corner he looks like he
opened up a homosexual hobo spindle
enough we're done it's it's like it's
almost like we started to shrink wrap
them
he looks like the debris he looks like
the debris of an arson at the yankee
candle factory
[Laughter]
he's like he tried to wrap a shower cap
around his arms he looks like it looks
like they made a suit out of all the
muppets
oh no cookie monster
oh
um
okay enough we're done
we don't i'm probably not okay let me
put that [ __ ] let me oh i okay the wrong
one uh we're good we have to move on
this is some serious stuff okay all
right now you leave me and my son alone
never talk to me or my son again
how does he look smaller
how'd you do this magic he got smaller
oh no
i'd like to point out that i think they
tried to use forced perspective to make
him seem the same size as the woman 20
feet behind him hold on royce
zoom out really fast okay hold on hold
on
remember me
a little boy i've got candy
oh no
[Laughter]
y'all
i can't breathe
by the way if you if you
you know the yellow dress to kind of if
you zoom out makes it look like he's got
a cape oh god he does
you broke me
[Laughter]
oh god oh my
god
oh yeah somebody said in the chat that
dan levy looks like he's wearing an aids
quilt
yeah but this one's actually covered in
aids yeah
it's an eighth quilt that has aids
inside of it it's like an aids quilt
that the colonists would have given to
the indians oh [ __ ] christ
oh
um excuse me it's an aids blouse
[Laughter]
oh god i can't see you have to wear my
eyes oh this seinfeld reboot is terrible
this is that pirate shirt right that he
was wearing yeah
enough we're done okay
we're not done
you want to know the best part
there are probably drag queens somewhere
being meaner
of course i hope so this is why i'm so
sad joan rivers is dead because imagine
her at this she would have [ __ ] she
would have just learned
these people
oh yeah i think we need to be kind to
parachute pants arms okay that's not
nice
elliot page would have would have
definitely killed himself
well ellen page is rolling in her grave
so no
oh no
um
just okay just two small titties
flopping around in a grave
just her tits are buried in the backyard
like a dead turtle oh in a shoebox like
a dead cat
it's got a little headstone
rip my tits
rip titties
when she finally gets the damn thing you
know they're gonna put her vagina down
there too and someone was [ __ ] with
her because it looks like they were
drawing dicks by her feet
you will never have this
hey don't we have a show to do yeah no
hold on i gotta send the link taper ask
me for the links here i'm going to send
you the link here you go taper
taper go send me the link i'm going to
i'm going to make it i'm going to make
her smaller
mr mr dax says are there any face masks
no you just have to listen to them and
watch their mouths move as they tell you
you have to wear yeah you have to you
you pour you you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
can tell who's part of the elite and
who's not yeah you could tell how else
are you supposed to know that you're
beneath them
holy crap this is one of my favorite
things on the internet and just in case
you guys worried i do i do have another
angle of the handsome boy
i don't know
worse i know
now he looks like he's eight
here you go taper enjoy do what you
gotta do
uh okay so you're ready for this first
day in this picture if you can whoever's
whoever's doing the uh the photoshop on
this you need to kind of make the uh the
yellow dress behind him look like a
little yellow tutu oh i like that kind
of has the
angle you know what i'm you know this is
an easy meme and i'm going to make it
probably after the show someone wants to
make it for me but at the top go i hate
first day of school pictures
oh
first date is a disney movie
well there's another one
another one
check the closet this was the gala party
oh yeah yeah there's a bunch of there's
not just one or two there's there's a
bunch of these photos um what is this
no
this is with katy perry
oh no
thank you kitty oh god come on that
actually fully checks out i mean that's
honestly that's the best one out of all
of them is she is she guacamole
i don't know man i think she's a big mac
jesus no i mean her dress is the big mac
she looks like she's covered in
guacamole hey royce yes
yes
check the closet
okay pessy
i didn't know
i didn't know donald had a new
buzzy posted on twitter all retweeted
that's really good oh no
it's all yours man i'm so [ __ ] i guess
hmm
god cam bro can we add an audio clip of
him saying i'll kill you
i kill you
or or
more fitting hey kill me
holy [ __ ] man this is
insane
oh [ __ ]
oh no there there might be another one
oh no i kept the puppets pants okay yes
that's what makes it is a little legs i
think the little legs they're actually
fitted better
oh boy okay here's
thank you king me me me here's a he sent
me one
there you guys go is it in the closet
it's in the closet now
oh i like it i like it here it is
call me rain
because i'm dripping
i love it that's amazing
so we're okay so you know guys 26
minutes we need to stop okay i actually
do have other stuff and sure we could
sit here and make fun
oh man we're children well that's a
child but
um
okay
some serious [ __ ] okay
that might be my favorite yeah it really
is
i already posted it on twitter oh i
retweeted it already
and i never post on twitter but uh i
don't know the original game review bra
ain't looking so good that's not review
bra
i don't know i don't want to make that
you know
assumption
okay i think we've milked this enough
right um
[Laughter]
what did you do
[Laughter]
that's it i'm done okay oh god i hope
you're not done because these are uh
well i'm done these are
too good
i'm done
i missed just i missed you guys i'm
gonna drink this little coffee here give
me a second
he's about to he's about to begin his
annual migration in mexico
glorious monarch leaving with the other
butterflies
he tries to go to mexico but he keeps
hitting the glass of the aviary that
he's in [ __ ]
oh god
all right enough
guys for real this time okay
we're moving on
you guys are making a mockery out of the
metro
look it's a serious event guys we should
not be making fun of anyone okay people
are dying right now how else are we
supposed to know that we have to wear
face masks and get vaccinated oh
jesus christ come on kid we're leaving
[Laughter]
let's go hold my hand come on i want you
to get lost in the crowd make sure you
look both ways yeah seriously oh now
rupert loves he's my favorite concise
conquistador no [ __ ]
can't talk
oh [ __ ]
boy
okay
we're good
okay i'm moving look you can see that i
am actually moving on okay look
all right i am actually i'm actually
moving on and we're no we're not are you
kidding me i'm just not gonna pretend
like this didn't happen
oh
this new fantasia movie looks fantastic
bessie by the way i gotta admit it's
really looks great
okay okay serious now look here we go
we're done see now we're actually done
okay